hello and welcome to this video playing
just kitten yeah I think I only had him
very recently right in some tirage mmm
this will probably not be a taraji even
though it can transpose if he goes ecigs
e63 3d five something like that oh I
can't go too far though maybe this is
not part of his repertoire d5 no does
not lead to a tirage yeah here maybe we
get some form of Taurus okay but i can
also go g3 and see what he does here
yeah 95 is some the most interesting
move but I must admit that i have looked
at the theory of this I mean I cannot
tell you how long ago a very long time
ago a success the normal move I think
and create form or even night a 3 has
been tried not sure about it night a
three is quite clearly a porn sack okay
I'll go for it clean air force a
traditional move I think then rugby ate
some rugby eight
yeah this is definitely a playable for
black grabbing that problem why does
some hoping for compensation on the dark
squares and of course my development is
also not that bad rook b12 into a five
maybe okay this looks normal anyway so
let's do it and it will be three I guess
and on D Phi there is e for ya if for
looks normal at same to try to exploit
the development well don't really see a
big drawback so you don't have to have
to go for it what is my idea here
probably maybe Bishop to g5 this is
something if he goes deform there are a
couple of options I probably can just
take C for them and then see that I can
get the pawn back later default looks
unlikely though some strange-looking
move hmm I'm not sure what black should
do here I don't think he's in bad shape
outside and I'm just just not sure what
I would do you definitely cannot take on
the form and well some some improvement
move like booty-eight is potentially
running into Bishop g5 things
which is the not looking ideal sort of
easy to play position for black jab
Bishop g5 but then there is d4
definitely and if I take all have six
less potential new 92 does not work okay
um so Bishop g5 I can also take first
eat eggs
it takes it takes Bishop g5 look some a
little bit kina actually Bishop f5 as I
don't mind much Saudi for Bishop f6
Bishop f6 92 especially eight so this is
not a problem okay well here I mean be
7s hanging and I can take potentially at
least 92 though Nestor Bishop yet okay
and so I might just take one of six or
not I can't actually do that later as
well but I think I'll take ok I cannot
do 95 now which I would like to do is d
for a move that is annoying
hmm definitely is
very difficult very difficult game d 494
I'm attacking up six not sure how much
that actually helps you might also just
take a three here mmm now that's an
interesting interesting decision Jim now
that Hanks and divorce in the it's also
possible so maybe this I'm struggling
here being two points down might get
default dag but all that is not not
really ideal
where I can't beat the beep on Hanks and
95 is probably coming
I could have taken be seven maybe why
didn't I consider that a little bit more
carefully don't know we should be some
or just be should be 349 teasing
probably this one going for work 27 may
for maybe coming I go 8-4 and okay i can
go 55 route the eight that's a bit
that's bad actually yeah I don't have I
don't really have a choice in check
check check maybe it's lost chad is
probably lost hmm maybe not check wait
for it just as I draw the game here
losing on time kicking f6 is drawing
very quickly because I'm trading off the
last pot yeah very bad technical player
black ok anyway mmm yeah that wasn't
great right that wasn't great that
opening I mean I have for half this half
compensation but it didn't really feel
like something great Teague's Teague's
yeah maybe I should have taken on d5 but
I didn't like that this looked far more
interesting but this should be six is a
good reply this disrupt you one Kim and
he could have played before I wasn't I
was gambling a little bit there that
didn't see that move which is very
annoying oops dad as he could have
played and won and win
greed and he played this okay here the
the game continues it's still not great
of course but I think it's it should I
should have very good drawing chances
here look forty three cows also very
Jewish but okay I tried this check yeah
look T for was a lot stronger of course
but he didn't do that and Here I am I
should never lose of course look before
was also interesting trying to play for
win check yeah I was just trying to play
in a way that i can make moves quickly
because of the time situation but it
wasn't was the best choice yeah totally
lost but he found all the way that it
actually got got to a draw position
night f1 still wins but okay I lost on
time Jim this opening is probably
something I should not repeat without
studying it in some detail it was too
too easy for him out of the opening okay
thanks for watching